I'm Richard Wrangham and my title is
Richard Wrangham
how it is that a pre-human ape became a
human and it's a question that Darwin
had no idea about really and that we've
had only some rather simple ideas about
until recently and I think we still have
a long way to go and until we have a
sense of the continuity in an
evolutionary sense and the biological
factors responsible for something like a
chimpanzee standing upright becoming
what we are today then we will always
have this sense of anthropocentrism will
always feel just a little bit divorced
from the rest of the universe and that's
one big question I think another huge
question is about the evolution of human
nature with respect to the the big
issues of cooperation pro-sociality
altruism and on the other hand violence
aggression our willingness to kill and
we are an unusual species because we
have such an extraordinary mix of these
two aspects we show them both two
extremes where amazingly more
cooperative than almost any other
species and were extraordinarily
destructive compared to most species and
grappling with the extent to which that
is a product of culture and biology and
to the extent of why we should have
biological predispositions to go in both
those directions remains one of the the
huge questions which again is something
of course that is hard to reconcile with
the rest of nature in many ways and for
that reason people resort to religion
and they resort to all sorts of from a
naturalistic point of view strange
belief systems to grapple with the
question of good and evil
well you talk about having your inherent
aggression in us sets off alarm bells
for some people because it sounds
biologically determinist it sounds
pessimistic so I wouldn't want to quite
put it in that term but I do think that
there's all sorts of evidence that
humans have got a predisposition to
behave with violence in certain contexts
that yes and that it's a great thing to
be aware of it and if the more were
aware of it and the more we can do about
it you know it has nothing to do with
whether or not one is optimistic or
pessimistic about the future and I'm a
firm believer in the fact that war is
not a necessary feature of human life
and that there has been a rather
impressive decline in the amount of
killing that humans as a species do over
the last centuries and millennia and
that the future can be expected to be
increasingly rosy but none of that is to
deny that within the human heart there
is a dangerous side
I think we can carry on doing the kinds
of things we are doing which is to think
deeply and carefully about anticipating
violence about setting up institutional
systems that enable us to anticipate
when there is a threat of genocide in a
country when there are threats of war
between - between states and for other
states to be prepared to intervene I
mean the great thing nowadays is that
whereas I in recent decades and
centuries when two countries declared
war on each other the others just so
stood by and watched nowadays everyone
is very scared and alarmed about it and
doesn't want this to happen and there is
intervention just flowing all over the
place you know we try and get involved
in Darfur we try and get involved in the
Congo we try and get involved in Bosnia
and as a result things change
size of the groups that our political
units has just been growing not exactly
steadily with with leaps and drops but
been growing over the millennia and
surely the way in which the human
species is ultimately heading is to it
towards a single group and to me they
one of the great questions of the future
is whether or not that group will be
achieved by unanimous pooling of the
decision to unite into conquering some
of the great problems of the world such
as climate change or food shortage or
the threat of aggression or whether or
not our the gloomy view would be that
the single united human group will be
achieved by domination and I think
that's on the whole unlikely I think
that the great value of the
technological advances that have been
happening in the last decades is that
people communicate enormous ly better
than they used to so that when there is
a problem in Fiji then the whole the
rest the world knows about it when there
is an earthquake in Haiti then within a
few hours everybody in the world knows
about it and is rushing to help and one
of the consequences of that sort of
communication ability is that the
dispossessed get a little bit more power
so in a general sense I feel that the
world is becoming increasingly
democratic there are more voices to
those that traditionally would have had
very little power indeed and that's the
kind of dynamic that will help avert a
hegemonic move towards a single world
government and instead something more
like what's happened in Europe with
countries just saying you know it makes
sense for us to work together
well in 1970 I was a newly minted
undergraduate looking for a research
project and I discovered about the
chimpanzee project and at that time I
was much more interested in questions
about what is responsible for species
differences in social organization than
I was in anything particular about close
relatives of humans I wasn't
particularly interested in chimpanzees
as a model or a close relative of humans
but simply because they'd be fascinating
species and it was very lucky time
because Jane Goodall was looking for
people to help her in her study so I
wrote to her and three week three months
later I think I was in Western Tanzania
at her site in in Gombe
she had a young son Grubb who was then
something like five or six years old and
so she was not spending much time at
this field site she was living mostly in
another place in Tanzania and Serengeti
National Park or just on the edge of it
and so her direct input was very much
producing a few great observations on
how to behave and then just letting you
run so I you know she would say things
like by all means collect your data
systematically but if you see something
really interesting make sure you go for
that instead of sticking to your formula
and she brought a tremendous sense of
intimacy and liveliness to the
discussion of the chimpanzees when she
would visit every few months because she
was just fascinated with the lives of
the individuals and for people like
myself who had been trained an ordinary
way in university life where our concern
was with enlarging the sample sizes and
making sure that you have everything
organized in a research design that
allows statistical testing and so on the
frank focus on what particular
individuals had done and how they seemed
to feel about others was refreshing
conceptually enlarging somewhat brave so
all a very good challenge and
complimentary perspective to more
orthodox training
well I did my PhD on the feeding
behaviour of chimpanzees and I think
that was a rather nice thing to be able
to study because life is in many ways a
search for energy and chimpanzees it's
like any other species have as a primary
concern just finding calories and that
is a key to understanding an enormous
range of behaviors so as I walked about
with chimpanzees I was seeing how they
were interfacing with the forest in a
very very direct way and seeing how they
had their behavior shaped by this primal
need so the size of the groups that they
were travelling in the distance they
were traveling per day the amount of
energy that they had for social
interactions the concern they had for
exciting things like hunting monkeys or
having sex or going on border patrols to
defend their areas all of these were
constrained and influenced very very
strongly by their route relationship
with food and unless you understand that
you don't understand the way animals
experience the wild and I think also you
don't understand the way that our
ancestors only a few thousand years ago
responded to the wild so it's a
wonderful foundation for thinking about
the influence of the natural world on
the more complex richer forms of social
behavior
so one of the things that happens with
chimpanzees is that they they use sticks
a bit like toys and it turns out that
the juvenile females use sticks in a way
that I suppose is rather unfamiliar to
us but basically they just carry them
around they'll just break off a stick
and and just carry it on their back on
their tummy keep it with them sit with
it while they're feeding and then after
a few hours sometimes if just a few
minutes let it go males will break off a
stick and and then guess what males will
do with it they'll use it to hit others
or throw it at others so it's kind of
like kids in the playground you know
they're not allowed any guns are not
allowed any dolls and what happens so
they the boys will pick up a rock and
use it as a gun and the girls may pick
up a gun and use it as a doll
well this gave the inspiration for a
study in which an undergraduate Rob
Tennyson has tested what a baby does to
play with a balloon both before and
after it sees somebody hitting the
balloon so this was a kind of shock
because first of all it turns out that
if you allow a baby to play with a
balloon and then allow it to watch both
men hitting a balloon women hitting a
balloon men cradling a balloon women
cradling a balloon then what the babies
do is change their behavior in one
particular way girls don't change their
behavior they hit the balloon before
watching they hit the balloon after
watching no difference the boys hit the
balloon before watching but after
watching then it turns out they hit the
balloon twice as much and what are they
watching while both boys and girls tend
to watch hitting more than cradling
because hitting is just a little bit
more exciting more interesting but
here's the amazing thing
the boys watched the man hitting and the
more they watched the man
hitting than the more they hit and the
girls watched the woman hitting and the
more they watched the woman hitting the
more they hit so this is domestic
violence model you know at six months
old he's a long pre verbal these little
babies are picking up on their own
gender and are responding by modeling
their behavior on their gender so it's a
wonderful interaction of biology and
culture because you know the boys are
hitting more than the girls as a
consequence of watching and so that's
something from within you know that's
that's some biological system that is
causing that and yet they've both been
socialized because they're both saying
hey you know mommy or daddy is doing
safe hitting
I'm gonna do some meaning to it means
that even at six months you've got to be
careful about what you allow your babies
to watch
well I mean uh when you look at primate
and we look at humans it's very clear
that in the majority of species
particularly closely related to us males
are in many ways more aggressive than
females and this aggression plays out in
a particular way so if you just talk
about gossip if you just talk about the
relatively low level kinds of
aggressiveness actually there's there's
no difference between men and women
it's when the aggression is really
costly to the victim it's when for
instance in in car accidents call them
accidents or call them something else
where the car is being used as a weapon
against somebody else men are far more
likely to be the drivers per million
miles driven
whereas in minor accidents men and women
are are equally likely so there's all
sorts of evidence that the men are more
violent than women and this is surely
significant when we think about the high
level interactions that occur in
interstate conflict so if you look at
the leadership styles of men and women
you find that women are more thoughtful
about the outcome of potential conflict
they are better at taking the
perspective of the opponent they are
less likely to be purely ego driven
simply wanting to be a superior to the
other side experiments show this and
analyses of particular interactions show
this so yes absolutely I think that when
in October 2008 I think it was Rwanda
became the first country in the history
of the world to have more men more women
than men in its it's national
legislative body in its Parliament that
was a great move forward and wouldn't it
be wonderful if we get more women
sharing with men
and the decisions that are so critical
to all of us about power relationships
because not to say that women will
necessarily always be peaceful is not to
say that they won't on occasion be just
as bloody and destructive in their
decisions as men might be but it is
going to tilt the balance towards a very
often a more reasoned and optimistic
outcome I think
I do think that people have not paid
enough attention in general when
thinking about sex role differentiation
to some very elemental things about our
domestic lives and so this relates to
the issue of cooking you know the fact
is that all the way around the world in
every culture except modern urban
industrial society
you can absolutely predict that women
are going to be doing the cooking for
men and the significance of women
cooking for men is that during the day a
woman is bound to the stove now you can
say that's because she's got small
children anyway and to some extent you
know that may be a contributor but for
whatever reason the fact is that in
essentially every society women are
responsible for the cooking whereas the
men are free to go off during a day and
do something nowadays the equivalent of
professional you're becoming a prescient
politician and then be fed by their
wives in the evening and of course in
the era of fast food and I easy meals
picked up at the supermarket it is a lot
easier for men and women to share the
domestic tasks and in in urban
industrial society that's what very
often happens and sometimes you get a
reversal in which men cook for women but
there's a I'm sure a huge sociological
momentum which has maintained this
tradition of women being domestic and
Men going off and being free to develop
their own professions so I notes you
know just as important as any kind of
tendency to do with men being more
ambitious for the rewards of a
professional work and the point about
the cooking is I mean a sense it's it's
old news but I think what's what's
interesting about it is that only
recently we started thinking about the
fact that this really makes humans very
different from our close relatives
because not close relatives you know you
never get women couldn't for men
as it were I mean there's no for anybody
because and so here we have a radical
new kind of system which I think has
enlarged the potential for patriarchal
domination by men of women once you have
the cooking system with the household
economy as we have it today then the
result is that you have this huge
freedom for men and not for women and it
exaggerated s-- any kind of previous
tendencies for sexually dimorphic
sexually different sex roles
the capacity or no that the the tendency
to accept evolutionary theory is of
course not just judged on the merits of
evolutionary theory it's judged because
it is seen as being in opposition to
religious belief and religious belief
carries with it not just the belief
itself in a particular set of facts and
ideas but all of the huge social and
political associations
so in in the United States if you don't
believe in evolutionary theory or if you
do believe in evolutionary theory then
it means it's harder for you to commit
yourself to a religious group that has
huge significance and so I think the
answer to why it is that evolutionary
theory is difficult for people in the
States to believe is that religious
systems are so incredibly prevalent and
why is that I guess I think it it
something to do with the United States
being a rural country and there's a lot
of association between rural living and
the importance of religious systems you
see it in the Middle East
you see it in Iran I suspect that as the
world becomes more urbanized you know
we've just passed the point where 50% of
the world's population live in cities I
think as this tendency increases
probably the importance of religious
belief systems will start declining or
will continue to decline and that one of
the consequences will be that there will
be increasing willingness to accept even
those aspects of science that challenge
religious belief
cooking is one of just the huge
influences on the availability of energy
and ultimately couldn't does much more
than provide energy but the first great
thing it does which has not amazingly
been appreciated until very recently is
that cooking gives us more energy than
eating our food raw and when our
ancestors first learned to cook then the
great huge initial impact would have
been that they got so much more energy
that they would have had more babies
than they had before and their babies
were to survive better and the adults
would have survived better simply
because they were able to eat more and
have more regular menstrual cycles and
put more energy into the immune system
so the first big thing about cooking is
it gives us a huge increase but we don't
know yet how much but a big increase in
how much energy we get out of our food
when I was studying chimpanzees I would
normally take sandwiches with me but
there were days when one for one reason
or another I didn't and because I was
studying the feeding behaviour of
chimpanzees I would regularly eat what
they in fact I yet as everything that
they had that I could find and on the
days when I didn't have any prepared
food with me I would try and rely on
what they had and you can eat it in the
sense that you can chew it up and
transfer it some of it is very strong
tasting which is kind of code word for
really unpleasant and some of it was
okay but it was not possible to find
anything that I could fill my stomach
with well the the short story is that I
realized after a bit that I simply could
not get enough energy out of a
chimpanzee diet and then I started
thinking well what what would be the
best place that you could get a raw diet
in the wild and there may be better
places than a chimpanzee forest I don't
think there are many and this set me off
looking for the different
between humans and other animals in
terms of their ability to survive on raw
food and I fairly rapidly discovered
that I although there are some myths
that go in the opposite direction
humans are different from every other
species because we have adapted
biologically such that we cannot survive
on raw food in the same way the other
animals can in some ways I shouldn't say
we cannot survive but but we can't
survive in the same way other animals
can in this sense that whatever
environment we're in raw food is an
unsatisfactory source and the most
dramatic example of this is that in the
best study of the people who choose to
live on raw food in modern urban
environments which is a great way to
lose weight and can be very healthy and
takes a lot of will but is nevertheless
it's got many admirable aspects but in
the best study of people who do that
then
first of all a high proportion of people
suffer energy shortage they just are not
getting enough energy to be able to
maintain their body as well and the most
dramatic point is that half of the women
who eat all of their food raw are a man
Eric that means that their ovarian
system has closed down completely now
this is despite the fact that they're
under ideal conditions they're eating
the best possible kind of food has been
domesticated it's no seasonal food
shortages because they're eating from
the global food resource when it's not
available in Germany you can get in from
Israel they're eating food that is
processed by blending and grinding and
many raw foodists an hour even drying up
to 114 degrees Fahrenheit they're taking
relatively little exercise compared to
if you're at the gathering in the hot
Sun so despite all these advantages
still 50 percent of women living on an
ideal raw food diet are unable to make a
baby in fact it's more than 50% because
those are the 50% that I could
a man a rig whereas the chimpanzee on
that diet will be pumping out babies so
humans there's clearly something
different about us and we actually know
what it is you compared to other
primates we have tiny intestinal volumes
compared to other primates we have these
very small guts and we have very small
teeth so these are signals of an
adaptation that occurred in our
evolutionary past to losing the ability
to eat raw food why should we do that
well because we were eating cooked food
and the cook food was great for us we
didn't need raw food anymore so get rid
of the ability to do it and that's what
we did so we've been committed to eating
good food for a period of time that is
still under dispute but I think it's 1.9
million years ago
there's this fascinating set of
possibilities that relate the size of
the brain to what has happened to the
reduction of our guts and the background
for this is that in order to understand
how brains get big over evolutionary
time you have to think both about the
advantages of being smart because that's
why of big brain of course and the costs
of fueling the brain because though our
brains are represent only was it 2.5
percent of our the weight of our body
they represent about 20% of our basal
metabolic rate so they are
disproportionately hungry in terms of
the amount of calories they consume and
that means that to have a big brain you
have to supply calories to it at a high
rate so how do we do that well is it by
having a high basal metabolic rate not
at all
we have exactly the basal metabolic rate
expected of any other primate is it by
taking some of the energy that we use to
feed some other organ and supplying it
to the brain yes it has to be so which
organ is it well in the primates the
only way that they can find energy to
give to their brains as it were is I
shouldn't say the only way but a major
way is through reduction of the size of
the gut those primates that happen to
have small guts because they happen to
be evolved to eat a high quality diet
are able to have some spare energy that
they would have used for bits of the gut
they no longer have and they divert that
to the brain in other words primates the
small guts have big brains well we have
the smallest guts of all we have the
biggest brains of all so it looks as
though there's a connection there and
since the reason for our small guts is
the fact that we cook that suggests that
it's cooking that really facilitated
this and by the way the time when our
brain really takes off in in size it was
about two million years ago the reason
that it looks as though we started
cooking about two million years ago is
that it's it's around that time 1.9 that
you first see evidence of
our ancestors having two signals that
are associated with a regard and that is
a narrower ribcage and a narrower pelvis
in addition you have for the first time
or note not the first time at that point
you have the biggest drop in the history
of human evolution in the size of the
teeth and chewing teeth
well that's associated with another
effect of cooking which is it makes your
food softer and because it makes you
food softer you don't need big teeth
small teeth seems to be an advantage
because maybe because they're less
easily damaged and big teeth so that
happens then and there was a third thing
that happens around the same time which
is that this is the point in our
evolution when we stopped being a plike
in the sense that we abandoned the the
morphology of the shoulder and the upper
arms that allowed us to climb now for
the first time why we look like us and
that means that we're not very good at
climbing in trees well that means that
we stepped on the ground and how are you
going to sleep on the ground in the
middle of Africa with elephants and
rhinoceroses and lions and leopards
around the only way that you would be
willing to sleep on that like that
nowadays is by the fire if you're out in
the open and so that suggests that that
was a time when our ancestors first
controlled fire enabled them to sleep on
the ground lose the climbing adaptations
softened the food get the teeth smaller
I took the food became much more
digestible and they could have a smaller
gut so those are all the things pointing
to cooking emerging immensely older than
people used to think and people used to
think maybe two hundred thousand years
ago but when I was saying 10 times as
far as that
raw foodists are romantics very often or
sometimes there is practical people who
discovered a way to make themselves feel
better I a common reason for eating raw
food is that people find that they have
reduced symptoms of allergic reaction
and it looks as though some people are
simply allergic to some of the
consequences of cooking so if you
discover that and you eat raw you'll
feel a lot better some people do it for
philosophical reasons that you know we
we are animals animals eat their food
raw so we ought to feed our food raw as
I say I think this is wrong because I
think we are the animals that have
evolved to eat our food cooked I'm I'm
full of admiration for raw foodist
because it's an incredibly difficult
thing to do I mean particularly when
people start they describe how much of a
struggle it is not to go out and get so
you know a candy bar some bread some
pizza whatever it is and it's a very
awkward way to eat because it takes for
a long time to prepare your food you
have to eat a lot because B you're
basically hungry all the time and so it
interferes with your social life raw
foodists tend to hang out with raw
foodists it changes a lot about your
life but for those people who find it
works for them it clearly works really
really well and there are a lot of us
who would like to emulate this because
it's a great way to lose weight you know
it's the ultimate way to control your
own body
yeah and the weight of months how does
this star work and all that sort of
thing I don't know I mean there's a
funny thing because people have long
noted that that cooking is is very
sociable we we like to eat with each
other around fire
we like to to bring the the food out of
the oven together and he has a meal and
yet there is no simple logical reason
there's no so technical reason why that
should be it's perfectly possible for an
individual to cook for themselves alone
for years as the model for Robinson
Crusoe did Alexander Selkirk in living
alone on a tropical island for years and
we could all be doing that in in theory
why we do it nowadays well I'm sure
there's lots of cultural history to that
but I'm kind of interested in the
question of of why it starts why the
pattern of people congregating in the
evening to share the evening meal why
does that happen in hunts and gatherers
and small scales open-air societies and
there I think one can make a reasonable
answer that it derives ultimately from
something a little bit competitive and
that is that anybody who cooks is giving
a clear signal to everyone else that
there is going to be food ready fairly
soon and they end up being vulnerable to
the hungry and the lazy and the
scroungers who for one reason or another
don't have any food of their own and
want to to take some and the short story
I think is that the tendency for us all
to congregate and eat meals together
represents the outcome of a system of
social regulation which is ultimately
designed to protect those who are
producing the food and I think the way
it works ultimately is that the women
end up producing the food there are men
who could take it and what happens is
that women marry and the husband is
functionally among his other very
important functions
he is there to protect her food from
some lousy bachelor who comes home who
is incredibly hungry and can't resist
taking some food off the fire as soon as
the cooks back is turned and you see
this written up and described in in
small-scale societies the the bachelors
are are thin and and hungry and nobody's
there to cook for them and they have a
problem and the married men are superior
to them and kind of keep them down so
that's one of the dynamics but it means
that it's great for husbands and wives
to eat together and of course the
children are there and then it can
extend easily to others in the camp and
suddenly got a rosy feeling and and now
now you can afford maybe in a sort of
regulated way to give food out to those
that don't have it
I don't know how the numeration ships
are going or where they will go I just
think there's going to be many fewer
constraints in the future there I think
in the past this has been a major
constraint the fact that you needed to
have somebody in the household cooking
for others and it was the women for I
think reasons because men were able to
get away with it that is increasingly
going to go away and isn't that great
you know we can get away from one
particular source of of sexist
unfairness and I think it heralds a a
much more exciting world in which women
are able to participate in the the
professions and the life of the
community to a far greater extent than
before
very bothered by the fact that humans
have not taken on board the degree to
which we are a dangerous species there's
a very wide sense that the default
conditions for humans if no bad person
comes along is that we'll all live in
peace together I'm kept up at night by
the notion that that's a dangerous
concept because it underestimates the
propensity for things going wrong and
I'm hoping that just as more more people
will understand evolutionary theory
where we come from and be real about us
in that way more and more people will
appreciate that we do have to take into
account our aggressive propensity
because when you do that then you can
design a safe world then you can
recognize when dangers coming so just as
people do recognize that men are
dangerous as potential rapists and we
take back the night and we don't allow
people to have dark areas in cities
where it's simply foolhardy for a young
woman to walk alone so life is safer if
we recognize the dangers and anticipate
them and that way we got a great future
well in the same way that we're doing
now I mean look what happened in Kenya
in 2008 you know there was a contested
election and stomache 2,000 people died
and that could have turned into a Rondon
genocide but actually there was huge
intervention and it was resented by the
president of Kenya but people slowly
came in with a single voice led by Kofi
Annan and said look you know we
recognize a tremendous danger here we
really care they worked for an intense
couple of months in particular and what
happens you end up with the president
and the prime minister from the rival
parties and they're working together
doesn't mean that peace will always
happen there there may be further
conflict but people are sensitive now to
the dangers and and that's what I think
is really important